are you picking up the sound of that
leaf blower
no i can't hear that okay
foreign
okay thank you
are we connected
okay good morning thanks for joining us
this morning from the department of
justice
uh we're here to announce several
criminal charges against
people affiliated with the people's
republic of china uh including five who
were arrested this morning on the east
and west coast
we're going to have three speakers today
the first will be assistant attorney
general for national security john
demers
the second will be the fbi director
christopher wray
and then joining us virtually will be
the u.s attorney
for the eastern district of new york
seth ducharme
following the initial remarks we will
have a question and answers period
where we'll take a few questions i would
advise that the reporters on the course
call
start queuing up now and the operator
will
now give you instructions on how to do
so we'll be back in about one minute
thank you
to ask a question you may press star
then one on your touch
film to withdraw your question please
press star then 2.
um
good morning today i'm joined by fbi
director chris wray
and remotely by the acting u.s attorney
for the eastern district of new york
seth ducharme to announce charges
against eight individuals
for acting as agents of the people's
republic of china
while taking part in an illegal chinese
law enforcement operation
known as foxhunt five of these
individuals were arrested across the
country this morning
three the rest we believe are in china
since 2014 at the direction of chinese
general secretary
xi jinping china has been engaged in a
global operation known as foxhunt
china describes foxhunt as an
international
anti-corruption campaign in which it
seeks to locate legitimate fugitives
around the world
to bring them back for trial in china
but this is certainly not the whole
story and oftentimes
it simply isn't true some of these
individuals
may well be wanted on traditional
criminal charges and some of them may
even be guilty
but in many instances the hunted are
opponents
of communist party chairman xi political
rivals
dissidents critics and in either event
the operation is a clear violation of
the rule of law
and international norms rather than work
with u s authorities for assistance with
recognized criminal cases as responsible
nations do
china resorts to extra legal means and
unauthorized
often covert law enforcement operations
without coordination with our government
china's repatriation squads
enter the sovereign territory of the
united states
surveil and locate the alleged fugitives
and deploy intimidation and other
tactics to force them back into china
where they would face certain
imprisonment or worse
following illegitimate trials
there are many established ways that
rule of law-abiding nations conduct
international law enforcement activity
this
simply isn't one of them operation
foxhunt is just one of many ways in
which china disregards the rule of law
china is also known for engaging in
among other things
extrajudicial pretrial custody
re-education camps under the guise of
counter-terrorism activity
refusal to fulfill its obligations under
mutual legal assistance agreements
providing safe haven to criminal
enterprises including
massive global hacking campaigns and
detention of foreign citizens for
purposes
of retaliation or political pressure on
those citizens
governments quite simply put hostage
taking
with today's charges we have turned the
prc's operation
fox hunt on its head the hunters became
the hunted
the pursuers the pursued
the five defendants the fbi arrested
this morning on these charges of
illegally doing the bidding of the
chinese government
now face the prospect of prison for
those charged in china
and others engaged in this type of
conduct our message is clear
stay out your behavior is not welcome
here
the charges announced today are an
unambiguous statement that the united
states will not tolerate
this type of flavoring conduct on our
shores
the department will continue to champion
the rule of law and work with our
foreign partners to ensure it is
respected throughout the world
the conduct giving rise to this case
investigated by the fbi
and prosecuted by the national security
division and edny was shocking
but standard operating procedure for
operation fox on
u.s attorney ducharme will provide more
details of the alleged crimes
but at its core this was a large-scale
and wide-ranging conspiracy
in which several representatives from
the chinese government traveled with the
elderly father of the new jersey-based
victim
in an effort to threaten him to return
to china
the same scheme also included leaving
menacing notes on the victim's door
imprisoning the victim's sister in china
and harassing
the victim's daughter online
the case is charged in part as a
conspiracy to act in the united states
as illegal agents of a foreign
government the department is committed
to the aggressive use of this statute
an important tool in our fight against
illegal foreign activity here
as well as other national security and
criminal tools
to combat operate china's operation
foxhunt
and any other unauthorized illegal
activity within the united states
before i will turn this over to the fbi
director i'd like to thank all the
prosecutors from the eastern district
and those here at the national security
division as well as the fbi agents from
around the country that investigated
this case
and conducted this morning's arrests no
law enforcement organization around the
world
does more to confront chinese malign
activity than the federal bureau of
investigations
director ray
good morning today's charges reflect yet
another example of china's ongoing and
widespread
lawless behavior and our refusal to
tolerate it
simply put it's outrageous that china
thinks it can come to our shores
conduct illegal operations and bend
people here in the united states
to their will in this case
once victims reported china's harassment
to the fbi we began a multi-year
investigation
in order to bring the perpetrators to
justice and vindicate
the rule of law and the fbi is proud to
have this investigation culminate in
criminal charges the first of their kind
charges that will help china understand
that surveilling
stalking harassing and blackmailing our
citizens and lawful permanent residents
carries serious risks that message
is particularly important because the
sad fact is that this was hardly an
isolated incident and china's tactics
have been appalling as assistant
attorney general demers described
foxhunt as a sweeping bid by general
secretary xi
and the chinese communist party to
target chinese nationals here
in the united states and across the
world who are viewed as
threats to the regime in another case
like this one when it couldn't locate a
fox on target
chinese government sent an emissary to
visit the
the victims family here in the united
states and the message they said to pass
on
target had two options return to china
promptly
or commit suicide and what happens when
the fox hunt targets
do refuse to return to china their
family members both here in the united
states and in china have been
threatened and coerced and those back in
china have even been arrested for
leverage
these are not the actions we would
expect from a responsible nation
state instead they're more like
something we would expect
from an organized criminal syndicate
it's important to understand that fox
hunt is part
of the chinese government's diverse
campaign
of theft and malign influence china is
violating laws
and norms left and right from
sophisticated cyber attacks targeting
our data and personal information
to economic espionage targeting our
intellectual property and our trade
secrets
and they're using that information to
gain influence on the world stage
to gain economic and political power all
to their benefit
and all very much to our detriment
so we've got to continue doing
everything we can to put a stop to it
i want to thank the folks in our los
angeles
newark new york and new haven fbi field
offices and i also want to thank all of
our partners
who helped with this operation at the
fbi we know we can't do it on our own we
need a whole of society response because
china is determined
to leapfrog the united states and become
the dominant global superpower
by any means necessary now before i wrap
up i also want to remind you of
something i've said time and again
our concern isn't with the chinese
people or with chinese americans our
concern
is with criminal acts committed at the
behest of the chinese government and the
chinese communist party
the fbi and our partners throughout the
u.s government will hold china
accountable and protect
our nation's innovation ideas and way of
life with the help
and vigilance of the american people
i'd like to close by saying that if you
believe the chinese government is
targeting you
that you're a potential fox hunt victim
please reach out
to your local fbi field office with that
i'll turn it over to the u.s attorney
for the eastern district of new york
seth ducharme to discuss the specific
defendants
and charges in this case thank you
thanks very much director wright it's my
pleasure
to be able to participate in uh in
today's announcement with you and aag
the merge to my knowledge is this is the
first case of its kind and i
i think it is significant for for a
number of reasons
um what makes the case really stand out
is that it directly involves the efforts
of a foreign power to conduct
unilateral activity here on u.s soil in
violation of our laws
more specifically the charges announced
today include
conspiring to violate 18 usc
951 which relates to the illegal
activity by foreign agents operating in
the u.s
without notice or permission of the
attorney general and conspiring to
violate title
18 united states code section 2261 which
relates to interstate stalking
i think it's important at the app that
to remind uh everyone
you know as always that the the charges
uh in the complaint that we filed today
are allegations uh they're simply that
and that the burden
of course is on us to prove those
allegations
beyond a reasonable doubt and the
defendants are of course innocent
until proven guilty we're going to
litigate this case in a courtroom
but with respect to that burden it is a
burden you know we hear
embrace to prove those facts
today's arrests of five defendants here
in the united states
arose from a long-term investigation
that we've worked collectively
with the fbi our partners in nsd
and a number of other agencies and we've
worked with offices
across the country because unfortunately
the conduct span multiple states
with respect to foreign government
officials they frankly have no business
operating unilaterally in our country
particularly where their tactics involve
intimidation and
show no respect for our principles of
comedy and our procedures
as aag demers has explained today's
charges arise out of the people's
republic of china's efforts
to use unlawful and frankly very
disturbing tactics
try to repatriate residents of the
united states
to the to china as part of the campaign
that they call
fox hunt now the criminal conduct set
forth in the complaint that we filed
today involves this conspiracy and
it involves people in the united states
and and people overseas who were working
at the behest
of government officials in the people's
republic of china
and they were engaged in a in an
international and interstate campaign
to threaten harass and surveil
uh our victim who we've referred to as
john doe one and we're going to
try to do our best to protect the
anonymity of that victim
john doe one is a u.s resident
as a result of this conduct which
occurred over a period of years
unfortunately
and involved operational activity from
coast to coast and around the tri-state
area
we charged eight defendants five of them
uh
were arrested uh this morning
um as alleged in the complaint which
uh there's much more detail in the
complaint i'm just gonna do my best to
summarize that a little bit
complaint on file is over 40 pages and
it's it's rich with facts but
essentially what it says is that over a
three-year period
members of the prc government directed
several individuals to engage in
unsanctioned
and illegal conduct in the united states
on behalf of the people's republic of
china
for the purpose of coercing a person
john doe one
to return to the people's republic of
china
we believe they did so because john doe
won and another victim his spouse
are alleged by the chinese government to
have committed some violations of
chinese law but rather than go through
the appropriate channels with the u.s
government to pursue those charges
prc officials and these defendants in
this case
engaged in extrajudicial conduct that
really violates not only u.s
law but the types of norms and
principles of comedy that we would
expect
from a foreign government the charge
conspiracy involved
efforts to pressure john doe one
directly
and also by taking actions that affected
his family members
including his wife his adult daughter
and other family members who resided in
the united states and some who resided
overseas in china
the effort was sustained relentless over
years
it involved some discrete acts to
frighten intimidate and coerce john doe
and it involved some
shockingly overt act it involves
surveillance including
we believe with the use of night vision
goggles involved leaving threatening
notes on the victim's doors
and i think perhaps most distressingly
uh targeting
the victim's daughter the efforts also
involve
seeking the assistance of a us-based
private investigator
to bend him to the will of this unlawful
mission
um to get into just a few of the
specifics
one of the notes read you know for
example quote if you are willing to go
back to the mainland
and spend 10 years in prison your wife
and children will be safe and all right
that's the end of the matter this is
conduct
we would not tolerate from our own
citizens
certainly not from our own officials it
constitutes
stalking and it is certainly not conduct
that we will tolerate
when conducted unilaterally by a foreign
government
with no notice and without the
permission of the united states
government
that is in summon substance what this
case is about
that's what led us to take what i
believe to be unprecedented action
to enforce the rule of law and
it's it's unacceptable and it and it
will not be permitted to continue
it's important i think also to note that
our investigation continues
and also to remind people once again
that these defendants like all
defendants are entitled
to their day in court today they look
forward to the burden to prove their
guilt is on us
and we embrace that burden i i just want
to echo
the the sentiment of director wray
where this a case like this really does
take a whole of government
uh approach we've had great partnership
with the fbi the national security
division
we got a critical assistance from the
department of homeland security and the
department of state
and our colleagues in the u.s attorney
community across the country
who really stood shoulder to shoulder
with us to enforce the rule of law
in this case is in all other cases so
thank you for the opportunity this
morning it's it's my understanding
that some questions now from the media
will be directed
to us thank you
we will now begin the question and
answer session to ask a question
you may press star then 1 on your
touchstone phone
if you are using a speakerphone please
pick up your handset before pressing the
keys
to withdraw your question please press
star then too
please specify who your question should
go to when your line is open
and limit yourself to one question you
may
return to the question queue with
additional questions at this time we'll
pause momentarily to assemble the roster
the first question comes from aruna
siswanatha
please go ahead from the wall street
journal
hi thanks for doing this so as you
mentioned
i think uh john timmers mentioned this
has been going on since
2014 and this is the first time you have
uh brought some cases here
is there have you seen an escalation in
um these kinds of harassment efforts
over the past
year or two or what kind of change have
you seen
are they being more aggressive about
targeting these people
our understanding is there are at least
two dozen sort of publicly identified
targets in the u.s
so i don't know that i could give you a
quantitative assessment
of the trend but i think it's fair to
say that this is
as i said in my opening remarks far from
an isolated incident
that's become all too common not just
here in the united states but
in a number of other countries around
the world who also respect the rule of
law
and some of the conduct that we've seen
here is
really beyond the pale and needs to be
stopped in the most firm manner possible
the next question comes from pete
williams of nbc news
please go ahead thank you mr ray where
were these folks arrested and
were they ever successful in getting
people to go back to china
uh well i'll i'll let uh uh seth speak
to
uh the last part uh but we uh had people
working both in our new haven
new york newark and los angeles field
offices
on the operation that took place this
morning
seth sure if i can
just add to that i think uh one of our
five defendants
was arrested in new jersey um
two were arrested in new york this
morning and uh
two others were arrested in california
[Music]
fortunately in this case as you know as
the facts we've
alleged set forth we were able to
essentially
uh protect the victim from intimidation
and and i can't really go beyond the
scope of what's in the public record
with respect to
other instances in which uh the chinese
agents may or may not have been
successful in their efforts but
unfortunately in this case we've been
able to protect the victims
the next question comes from nick
schifrin from pbs
please go ahead thanks for doing this
can you
discuss who the five who you've arrested
are who you believe they were working
for and how they entered
the united states whether they lied on
any visa applications and you've
mentioned xi jinping
multiple times i can imagine that you
have connections
to these people to prc officials
but do you have personal uh evidence or
evidence that xi jinping personally was
involved
so so this is that i'm not sure who the
question was directed to but
i can talk about the defendants a little
bit
so with respect to the five defendants
who were arrested today
just briefly uh hungarian was a
30 year old naturalized u.s citizen
he resided in queens new york jyn
participated
in the scheme to stalk our victim john
doe won
in or about april of 2017 by assisting
with the travel lunch and logistics
planning for zhufang
and some prc officials as well as
assisting with the surveillance
on john doe one and his father
with respect to ju young
i can tell you that yang
who's also known as jason zhu he's a 64
year old prc citizen
and a legal permanent resident of the
united states he resides in flushing new
york
he was involved in hiring the the
private investigator michael mcmahon
to help investigate and surveil and
ultimately stalk
john de juan on behalf of the prc
government
um michael mcmahon is a 53 year old u.s
citizen he's a licensed private
detective in new jersey
and he was essentially recruited and
hired to assist with surveillance and
conducting other aspects of the
operation
rong zhing is a 38 year old u.s legal
permanent
resident and prc citizen he resides in
california
his role essentially was seeking
location information
for people in the united states on
behalf of the prc government
and then with respect to the fifth
defendant who was arrested today
zhang ying
he's a 24 year old prc citizen
and a legal permanent resident
zhang resides in brooklyn during the
relevant time period at least and
now he resides out in california where
he was arrested
earlier this morning so hopefully that
that's some helpful background on the
defendants
and responsive to your question thank
you
the next question comes from eric tucker
from the associated press
please go ahead hi thank you so much for
doing this i was wondering and this
question may again be for for seth or
for john
um i was wondering if you could talk a
little bit about what the
value to the prc was or the individuals
who were being targeted what was it
about
them and their backgrounds that led um
to this very aggressive and illegal
pursuit
were they themselves sort of active
dissonance of the prc or was there
something else that made them so
significant to the government
thank you thanks very much eric i think
you know we don't want to go further
into why these specific individuals were
targeted were very keen
to protect their identities and
obviously any information that we give
along those lines could be used to
uh reconstruct who these folks were so i
think we'll leave it as what was in the
indictment
with of course the overlay i think as
your question recognizes that
while some individuals are legitimately
sought
for criminal activity although
in an illegitimate way others in fact
are
dissidents critics rivals of
the chinese general secretary thanks
this now concludes the press conference
you may now disconnect
you